Cody is with us in Beaumont Texas
hey Cody how are you better than I
deserve
what's up okay so I'm 22 years old I
don't have any debt other than our
normal bills and you know I know we're
not supposed to but we're renting I'm my
income kind of berries I make usually
around $3,000 a month so I'm living
about $36,000 a year I just had a
seven-month-old we paid for all the
medical bills out-of-pocket before he
was even here out of checks or out of
just normal income I'm getting married
in April I'm just trying to figure out
what next best plan for me is to do
great well you're doing really really
well with your finances very well done
you said we're not supposed to you mean
you're not supposed to have dad or
you're not supposed to be renting I know
my dad watches your show I'm actually a
first-time listener my dad watches your
show and he's told me from watching you
you know you're not really supposed to
ring it you're supposed to buy if you
can because basically you're just
throwing money away on renting kids
you're not going to get anything out of
the investments no return well that
would be true that would be true over
the long haul but on the short-term know
you're 22 you've done a great you said
20 or 22 22 you're 22 you've done a
great job you're debt-free you know
everything is going good we're getting
married everything's happening here
right the life is good you got no
troubles so the first thing we teach a
process of building your wealth or
building handling your money called the
baby steps baby step one is to save
$1,000 cash as a starter beginner
emergency fund you've done that too yeah
we've got like three or four okay two is
to be debt-free everything but your
house and you don't own the house and
you're debt-free
so you've done baby step two baby step
three is to raise that $1,000 account up
to three to six months of expenses as a
good rainy day fund that's your next
goal okay okay so let's take the $3,000
you have
saved and start adding to it by living
on a written budget every month giving
every dollar a name which by the way is
really good pre-marriage counseling for
you and your fiancee to do that together
okay and certainly after you're married
to do it together for the rest of your
lives where you spend the money on paper
you have been very responsible and
pretty frugal to be able to pull off
what you've done so far
so you're already yeah you've already
got the right spirit to do this all
we're gonna do is kind of polish it a
little bit by living on a detailed plan
when you start making every dollar on
paper behave and the two of you are
agreeing about that you're agreeing not
only about your money then you're
agreeing about your goals right because
you're making those we're agreeing that
we're not going to spend money over here
because we're saving for our rainy day
fund and then the next thing I want you
to say for after the rainy day fund is
to start thinking about saving for a
down payment on the house and so you're
not buying a house until maybe this time
next year or even later okay that's okay
it's okay there's no panic you just
don't want to wake up at sixty eight
years old and I've been a runner your
whole life because you didn't have a
plan you know exactly but but it was
another question I had was when you go
to buy a house what do you how do you
know what you really want your your
spending limit to be on a house you
don't want the payment to be more than
one fourth of your take-home pay on a
15-year fixed-rate mortgage okay 15-year
fixed-rate no more than a quarter of
your take-home on them on exactly if you
were to go get a 30-year adjustable rate
they will qualify you and loan and loan
you money for twice as much house as I'm
talking about okay so I'm putting you in
about a half the house that the mortgage
company if they maxed you out on the
least payment possible like most people
do stupid people right and they go they
go in debt to their eyeballs and they
can't breathe in the house owns them
they don't
and the reason I want you to do that
doesn't want to leave wiggle room in
your budgets so you can start a college
fund for your baby you can start
retirement you know and you can start
talking about getting this house paid
off then a lot sooner than 15 years and
so you're tracking towards every bit of
that Cody you're doing good stuff here
but no rush nothing panic nothing on
fire about buying the house buy a house
but do it in the right order so that the
house is a blessing and not a curse when
you buy a house and you're broke you
have no money in a bunch of debt which
is what most people do the house is not
a blessing buying real estate is not
always a good idea and so you get
yourself on a good solid footing where
you have that emergency fund in place of
three to six months of expenses which
you know it's probably ten thousand
bucks for you okay and then above that
you save a good strong down payment on
the house over the next year and so you
got some a lot of savings to do the next
year including getting married you know
so you know or more it may take you a
little longer in a year save up your
down payment and your emergency fund
but you move in the house that way and
you keep that payment down to 1/4 of
your take-home pay on that 15-year fixed
conservative like that your the house
will be a blessing you'll enjoy it and
it won't be this burden hanging around
your neck choking you to death all the
time
amen thanks for the call hang on I'm
gonna give you a copy of the book the
Total Money Makeover which explains this
whole process in detail because you are
definitely on fire you're ready and this
will walk you through exactly what to do